what do you think about kamu as a writer
I don't like his novels at all oh you
don't at all yeah you talked about
the plague to me I didn't I I think the
book is pointless it's fascinating
because all you need to do is read the
synopsis and then you get it like I
don't think his book isn't that true for
most books no I mean like you could take
I I don't know I just don't agree at all
there I mean it's it's catcher in their
ey there's a lot of books that are
seemed trivial I don't think seems
trivial but I think animal
farm animal farm is a methodical
stepbystep examination of a
transformation from one thing to another
the plague is not that it's a
methodical
examination of what a society is like
under the plague which could symbolize a
lot of things including the plague
directly or Nazi Germany or ideological
movements or it's it's similar to Animal
Farm maybe not as effective in terms of
using this kind of symb animal farm has
a narrative and I'm going to spoil the
whole plague the book The Plague okay
there's a there's a town I believe in
Oman mhm a plague descends people
struggle to deal with it and the plague
vanishes as quickly as it came the
end yeah but there's the victims the the
people that take advantage of it there's
the doctor that amidst the absurdity and
the evil of the plague is fighting to do
good nothing for me does nothing okay
well I can spoil an animal farm there's
uh pigs there's animals at a
farm and they the humans are abusing
them and then the animals overthrow the
humans but
then the
pigs uh become just like the humans it
the lesson kids is that uh power
corrupts no matter whether you walk on
four or on two I thought the lesson was
that pigs are the most human-like
animals on the farm I thought the I
thought the lesson was that there's no
Sugar cany
Mountain that's
really